what's the best and what's the worst mr.
McGee before what's a spife for me was
not having any facial hair which is
quite a it's a signature looks words
well but I don't have a beard so I
avoided all sorts of trouble that way
you know sticking out in the morning
having food pardon this all the kind of
thing got a bit of slagging over it you
know a chaired a little bit put out a
snap you know from having a beard and
the worst part
I hung over the worst part is it's a
complete or aspire to be you dwarf there
are a great sort of species of people
that lawyer in the family they hold out
those kind of after these very strong to
the heart you know when they get on with
it they would do a bicker all day
between themselves but anyone else an
outsider comes in they all stick
together kind of like that community
sense of it happen buddy Scooby you
involved on the last story was that
unexpected for you and enemies it was
expected and I was so embarrassed
obviously something it's not in the book
but um but I think it's important to say
Terios and the leading female character
and I think it's important to have you
know little girls and boys go to the
cinema see a
it was really strong as I've
disappointed and remembering around
trying to find our boy it's it's right
and she's awesome
tell us why they tended ah they're too
old to be jealous they couldn't have her
anyway you know who else is gonna get
her kill ich answer me
you